we've surpassed a pretty important
number more than half of the country now
believes that Donald Trump should not
only be impeached by the House of
Representatives but also removed by a
Senate conviction now I still don't
think it's going to happen but if
anything we'll make it even a remote
possibility as I've said before it's if
even Republican opinion turns in that
direction I don't believe it will happen
because 62% of Trump is said there is no
way ever that they will abandon Donald
Trump but let's take it one step at a
time we have a new ABC if so's poll in
which 51% 51% of Americans believe that
Donald Trump should be removed from
office via impeachment this is more than
half the country 70 percent believe that
Donald Trump was wrong to pressure the
Ukrainian president to launch smear
investigations into Joe and hunter Biden
now you might see these numbers and
think well 51% of the country wants
Trump removed certainly he will lose
re-election in 2020 right well no
because remember many Americans don't
vote 51 percent 60 percent even 65
percent of the country
might want Donald Trump removed but half
the country doesn't vote and if it's
more of the people on our side than the
people on Trump's side that choose to
stay home in November of 2020 he can
still easily get reelected particularly
because of the electoral college system
however a relevant comparison is that
these numbers are more aggressively
against Trump
then how public opinions saw Richard
Nixon at this early stage of the
impeachment inquiry during the 1970s
that doesn't bode super well for Donald
Trump now in the don't impeach Trump
side there are a few shades of opinion
there are sort of some there's some
fracturing going on that's important to
think about you've got conservative
Republicans who don't think Trump is a
good president they may even think what
Donald Trump has done is wrong with
Ukraine emoluments Yemen whatever but
they just don't think it rises to the
level of warranting impeachment okay
that's one sort of group that's kind of
like maybe the National Review
possession a position in fact rich Lowry
might even have written something like
this in the National Review and it's
gone
into my my brain somehow and I don't
remember the specifics but this is what
I would guess is sort of like a National
Review rich Lowry position on
impeachment then you've got the sort of
mildly ignorant Republicans who aren't
necessarily big Trump brown nosers but
they rest easy on talking points like
all politicians do bad things or I'm not
really affected by this personally so I
don't care or the stock market's doing
well or whatever that they don't really
have to think about wow maybe I should
be thinking about voting for a Democrat
in November of 2020 that's I know that's
like an in-between sort of crowd and
then you have like the real pro Trump
sycophants who can see Trump do no wrong
and will defend him no matter what he
does according to a recent poll that's
62% of Donald Trump supporters who are
in the even hypothetically I can't think
of anything Trump could do that would
make me question my support for him so
step one is Trump has to be removed
however voted out impeachment as
unlikely as that would be step two is
that a lot of those people who right now
have these milquetoast views on Trump
the right-wingers who don't like him but
they don't really see him as a big
problem we're gonna have to deal with
that and this is why I've been talking
for months now if not longer about the
damage done by Trump will outlast his
presidency because when Donald Trump is
removed or goes away you know whatever
goes away ends his second term is
removed after one term is impeached
whatever the case may be we are going to
see some people take the position of
well Trump is gone so the Republican
Party is fixed everything's back to
normal the country's back to normal
aside from the policy issues and the
alliances that have been destroyed in
our reputation which has been a
laughingstock for a couple of years you
have to remember that the Republican
Party is responsible for the
circumstances that got us to a point
where Donald Trump was able to win a
Republican primary and then a national
election in 2016 and they have been
unwilling to deal with him and that
throughout his presidency so it will be
really important that whenever Donald
Trump ultimately leaves office it has to
be made clear that the Republican Party
still as much of a problem as it was in
the lead up to Donald Trump becoming
president and throughout his presidency
this may be a conversation that is not
relevant until January of 2025 if Donald
Trump wins re-election it may be
relevant much sooner if Donald Trump
loses re-election or even in the
unlikeliest of scenario scenarios is
removed via impeachment sooner than that
much like Republicans normalized george
w bush and now have actually even helped
to rehabilitate his image although
donald trump has certainly played a role
in rehabilitating w's image as well the
same sort of indifferent Republicans who
don't love Trump but they don't see him
as a systemic menace they may be able to
rehabilitate their own image if it's not
made clear that Trump is the outcome of
how they allowed the Republican Party to
change over the last many years it is
not merely a blip on the radar it is the
conclusion it was the end to the means
so to speak that was the radicalization
D intellectualization I know that's not
the the right word or maybe even a word
but I think you know what I mean and
cartoon if ocation of the Republican
Party over the last many years and
particularly much of that was catalyzed
and aggravated by their deep hate of
Barack Obama some of which was racially
motivated and some of it some of some of
which was not but we will talk about
that when the time comes in the time
maybe soon the time maybe in January of
2021 it may not be until January 2025
hopefully that's not the case